Good morning, John.
I know, I'm too late, I don't know what I'm thinking,
I'm on the wrong side of the Bell Curve, I'm catching the wave as it crashes but
I simply ... cannot ... help myself.
[Music: Do The Harlem-]
[Music: Promise - Komi Hirose]
[Music: Dragostea din tei (aka Numa Numa) by O-Zone]
[Music: Gangnam Style - PSY]
[Music: Promise - Komi Hirose]
I guess... I'm a little bit of an Internet dance craze hipster, it turns out
I mean, yeah, it's great, Harlem Shake,
but don't forget about Gadan, people
Its feelings might get hurt, and Numa Numa? C'mon!
Alright, because I can't help but not think too much about... everything.
I am really curious as to why internet dance craze videos often... seem to be bilingual.
English and Spanish.
English and Japanese
English and Korean
English and Moldovan
English and ... Soldier Boy.
Of course, it is important to note that this trend pre-dates internet culture.
And also it is still completely possible in the Internet Age to have a dance craze based on a unilingual song.
But it is definitely a majority and it is definitely a trend, and I definitely don't know why.. it is...
... though I have some little guesses but they're not good enough for the light of day, I don't think.
So. Ideas? ... comments.... help.
Alright, enough of that. You people are probably waiting for me to talk about something else.
I'm kind of avoiding it, 'cause it's freaking me out.
It has been a big week in ... [Hank does mouth sounds]
John. You, my brother, John got to interview the President a bit. Which was cooool.
Here's a highlight:
[John]: Almost all economists agree that we should stop minting pennies. It's a really obvious thing...
... it's not a particularly interesting or partisan thing, but it's really obvious.
So my question to you is why haven't we done it?
[Pres. Obama]: You know, I gotta tell you, John, I don't know. [stumbles for words]
It's one of those things where I think people get attached emotionally to the way things have been.
[Hank]: John Green - you stumped the President... Pretty cool.
But in addition to that, The Brain Scoop was featured on NPR.
Wheezy Waiter and Shay Carl got to make a video with Matt Damon who ...
... you may or may not know is my idol.
Lizzie Bennett Diaries won two Streamies. These are the pre-awards. We may still yet win more.
And we launched Crash Course: Chemistry, which I'm very excited about.
And I got back from the United Kingdom, so I don't really know what time it is.
And... oh yeah. Also, the President refused to name your unborn child.
[Pres. Obama]: If I gave a preference and you guys went the other way, forever this child would say...
... "The President doesn't like my name".
The main thing is tell either Eleanor or Alice to not to forget to be awesome.
[Hank]: What?!
[Hank makes more mouth sounds while a Harlem Shake/mix song gradually fades in]
[Dance music mashup by Maxton]